all right let's answer some questions
john pascal asks what's the unofficial
desean watson trade deadline in my view
i mean unofficially i just think you got
to get it done and you got to put it
through on march 17 because what happens
is teams that are interested in desean
watson are going to go find other
quarterbacks
and and then they're not going to be in
a position to trade for deshaun watson
so yeah at the very latest the draft but
i think you got to get this thing done
and in place
so you have maximum suitors at the table
because if you don't if you wait around
teams aren't going to wait around for
you and they're going to address their
quarterback needs elsewhere and those
teams are going to drop out of the mix
and it's going to be harder to maximize
the leverage sharing
mike you made the great prediction
before the season started that the tampa
bay buccaneers will win the super bowl
today is what february 11th i'm going to
make the prediction because i know that
the texans are not looking at the trade
to sean watson as of today i'm going to
make the prediction that this drags out
beyond the draft
and watson holds out and
they come to a head at some point over
the summer which was far too late in
which case the texans gets far too
little that they should get for deshawn
watson i just have a feeling this is not
going to end well for the houston texans
yeah see the problem is
the texans have done nothing in recent
months to show us that they know how to
properly solve a situation like this and
how to maximize their leverage and it it
will be very easy for a guy like jackies
to be and cal mcnair who haven't really
been around the block many times to make
the smart
objective
decision free of any passion or or or
desire to be tough or send a message or
not let the inmates run the prison which
was the catchphrase for the organization
a few years ago and they're potentially
going to put themselves in a spot where
it's going to be painful it's going to
continue to be a distraction it's going
to continue to hover and they're
ultimately going to get less than they
could have gotten when they realize
that's their only play because i think
watson has made it clear
that's their only play and i'm not
convinced they're going to do the right
thing
dr j 144 are the texans at risk of doing
anything which would anger the other 31
owners or would the other 31 be happy to
see a franchise implode like this
franchises are both competitors but also
colleagues correct and that is true
but
the teams that get it the owners who get
it
are very happy to have
a collection of competitors who don't
get it because it doesn't get so bad
that it affects the collective ability
of the football teams in the nfl to earn
money i mean the nfl isn't going to
start losing money because there's a
dysfunctional team
so it's good you just cross them off the
list this is a team we don't have to
worry about so i don't think it's ever
going to get to the point where the
other 31 owners are are wishing for the
opportunity to force a sale or something
like that they like having dysfunctional
teams around and they're not going to
have any complaints about the texans
being dysfunctional shireen
you look at how long the texans i don't
want to say dominated the afc south but
they certainly were competitors in the
afc south and won a number of division
titles i think the other teams in the
afc south are thrilled with what's
happening in houston they will be
thrilled if desean watson gets traded
that's one less team that they have to
worry about in the division every year
when you look at the colts and how close
they came to losing both the games
against the texans this year they'll be
happy if deshawn watson leaves and the
texans are in dysfunction for a long
long time
one time i was in the presence of an
owner who lives in the city where his
team is located shows up at the facility
on a regular basis
and he was asked his opinion on another
owner who is an absentee and isn't there
all the time and what do you think of
that and the response was i love
competing against him and that's that's
the mindset that's the attitude the
owners who know what they're doing very
much like to have owners in the league
who by all appearances don't know what
they're doing matt evon with the salary
cap shrinking should free agents wait a
year to sign long-term deals and ride
out 2021 on one of your contracts well i
think what they should do preliminarily
is see what's out there and if you have
a long-term offer that is acceptable you
take it
but if you don't get an offer that you
think is appropriate to your skills and
abilities then that's when you do the
one year deal but when you're talking
about really good money for one year
versus generational wealth life-changing
money on a long-term deal with full
guarantees and all the bells and
whistles if you're one of those guys
then you take it i don't think you enter
the process saying i'll just take a
one-year deal and do it all over again
next year that's your fallback shireen
once you realize that the money isn't
going to be there the way you thought it
was
yeah you look at some of those free
agents in tampa specifically mike chris
godwin lavonte david um shaq barrett if
those guys get long-term deals elsewhere
that are acceptable and i think all
three might
then you go take that if they don't then
i think they should return to the bucks
for a one-year deal for whatever the
bucks are going to give them and go try
to win another super bowl that's
probably their best option but if they
get those long-term deals elsewhere you
have to go you have to go take that
money because as you said mike it's
generational wealth and it sets you up
for the rest of your life
shaq barrett said earlier today on
sirius xm mad dog radio that it's time
that he break the bank now the
buccaneers could tag him again at
18.99 million for one year the ideal
situation would be to finally work out a
long-term deal but that's just one of
the issues that the buckingham is going
to have and frankly if they do a
long-term deal the cap charge for this
year would most likely be significantly
less than 18.99 that's another reason
for the two sides to work something out
but 18.99 is the starting point on a
long-term deal because that's the bird
that he has in the hand at jimmy luck
will we see more and more players try to
force trades well we see
non-quarterbacks do this too well jimmy
it started with non-quarterbacks it
started with antonio brown two years ago
and we talked last week to stefan diggs
about it you know all it took was one
tweet the day that kirk cousins got his
extension coincidental possibly not
coincidental possibly that's when stefan
diggs took to twitter and by that night
they had a deal so
i think that it's overdue for the
franchise quarterbacks who had
traditionally been company men
to say you know what
we're not playing this game anymore
we've got power we've got leverage we've
got options and we're going to start
exploring them and i think that between
what we've seen other players do who
aren't quarterbacks and what tom brady
was able to pull off last year that's
caused this critical mass for deshaun
watson russell wilson maybe aaron
rodgers next year and other guys who are
going to be thinking i'm not stuck with
the team that drafted me for my entire
career or until they decide they're done
with me i can force the issue if i'm not
happy where i am
yeah you look at jalen ramsey khalil
mack i mean the list is long mike of
non-quarterbacks who forced trades and
that's what set all this up for
quarterbacks to go hey we should be
doing the same thing and now here they
are we're going to see a lot of these i
think this season probably into next
year
what's jamal adams going to think
if russell wilson gets traded
after jamal adams finally found a place
where he can win some football games
you trade russell wilson it may be a
little while until the seattle seahawks
win some football games and it may be
jamal adams wants to be part of the
package wherever russell wilson goes
along with dk metcalf along with tyler
lockett uh but we'll see how that plays
out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports